welcome back Alex Jones is a conspiracy
theorist who made hundreds of millions
of dollars spreading the outrageous lies
at the Sandy Hook shooting was a hoax
The Grieving fames finally sued him for
defamation and they rewarded more than a
billion dollars but so far he hasn't
paid them a dime this is what happened
last time I tried to hold him to account
do you feel a sense of personal regret
and remorse that your actions on air
that your actions on air
inspired a lot of people to think these
people were actors and their kids didn't
die do you feel genuine remorse you let
me talk for any 500,000 Iraqi children
starve to death did it on purpose and
you no I feel way less no I legitimately
question Sandy Hook and I stand by what
I did said it was a fake and a hoax you
let me finish I'm not going to come back
on your show in 10 years and you'll say
do you now apologize if I sat here and
slit my throat on air it wouldn't be
enough for you one this weekend Alex
Jones was banned from all mainstream
social media media platforms now Elon
Musk has restored him to X formerly
Twitter extolling his commitment he says
to free speech but where is the line on
free speech and does Alex Jones cross it
here's a debate it's a journalist Glenn
Greenwald aggressive commentator namiki
const and YouTuber Mark mein also known
as count danula welcome to all of you
okay Mark you're with me so let's start
with you um what what do you feel about
this I mean I've written a column for
the New York Post saying I think it's an
outrageous decision by Elon Musk who
only a year ago himself said that
because one of his children had died in
his arms his own kids that he never
wanted to see anybody who would profit
from the death of children for personal
gain for fame or politics now he's done
a u-turn on that is he right yeah I
think he's completely right in doing it
El on must company so if he wants Alex
Jones back on the platform then he
absolutely can and he did put it to a
poll to the public you know Vox poopular
Vox day and uh people said they wanted
them back in the platform so he's
brought them back on the it's an amate
poll 2 million of his followers voted we
don't know how many times each one voted
etc etc it's not a sophisticated each
can only vote once yeah but but my point
is is there a line though on free speech
at all for you for me personally no
nothing no I think that Alex Jones
should be able to go on Twitter if they
want him there then that's fine they can
have him there and he can do you think
what he said about the Sandy Hook
massacre was justified then Justified
like he has the right to say it I don't
wouldn't say it was justified I mean 1.2
billion do worth of Damages awarded
against him for one of the most serious
suit against an individual in the
history of one of the worst defamations
actually in terms of Damages America's
ever seen damages and defamations not
protected by the First Amendment and yet
you think he was entitled to say it I
think he had a right to say it he a
right to to say that a mass shooting
that killed 20 young kids was a fake and
a hoax that the parents of The Grieving
dead were crisis actors these were
statements which he repeatedly made
which led to actual intimidation
harassment death and rape threats and
people in the street going up to these
people and confronting them these
parents you think all that is fine I
don't think it's fine I never said it's
fine I said I said he has a right to do
it does he have a right to do yeah
agreeing that someone has a right to you
think he has a right to do that yeah I
think he has a right to do it agreeing
that someone has a right to do something
isn't the same as agreeing with what
they say no no I
agree you actually think he has a right
to do what he did with the consequences
we now know happened yes basically yeah
a bunch of Nutters did do a lot of awful
stuff after the fact but that's
basically going down the same route of
you know remember back in the '90s they
wanted to ban video games and Dungeons
and Dragons because they thought it
caused violence and devil worship or you
can't you know engage with this type of
you know media otherwise it's going to
cause XYZ like rap music causes violence
all the other nonsense if we're saying
oh this guy is not allowed to say his
conspiracy theories or whatever you want
to call them because some crazy guy out
there might do something mental then
nobody can talk about anything at all
well you can you just there are limits
to free speeches there are everything
else even First Amendment America has a
number of limitations to it let me go to
namaki k namaki what is your response to
Elon Musk putting Alex Jones back on
X what I find so fascinating about Elon
Musk is he had he uses a very loose
absolutist definition of free speech for
his needs but for his company uh but
doesn't use the same standards for say
the algorithm I mean he has no problem
giving Russian Bots that boost some of
these guests on the show uh with the
Free Speech rights but does not give
people of color and women the same
rights so this is not an equal playing
field
uh number one they're not the government
number two they're not following the
United States Free Speech laws there is
there are limitations as you said
incitement defamation fraud threats
child porn obscenity those are uh the
limitations to free speech and there is
a whole lot of that going on on Twitter
so if he wants to be an equal playing
field Free Speech absolutist then clean
up the Bots uh clean up the algorithm
make it completely transparent and
democratized and let people like me and
people of color and smaller accounts
have the same uh effect as say someone
who's being boosted by Russian Bots okay
let me bring in Glenn greenell Glenn you
know you like me you're a big supporter
of the principle of free speech and
let's just lay that on the table I call
this show uncensored because I want it
to celebrate Free Speech but I've always
been aware there are limitations and
under the First Amendment which is one
of the greatest Protectors of free
speech anywhere in the world defamation
is not protected under the First
Amendment and this was clearly one of
the most serious defamations of a body
of people that America has ever seen so
I don't understand why just for that
reason alone why Elon Musk has performed
this U-turn with Alex
Jones I think the issue peers is what
they do on the platform we have all
kinds of terrible people using social
media we have people who lied the United
States into a devastating war in Iraq
including the current president of the
United States we have people who defame
all the time like the guest I just heard
in my ear tried implying though she
wasn't courageous enough to say who she
meant that one of the people on this
panel is promoted by I'm sorry I don't
know why I'm hearing a voice in my ear
because I'm not actually done talking
yet so the standard peers that Elon Musk
enunciated when he first bought uh
Twitter is one that I supported even
though he hasn't always adhere to it
which is as long as people are using
that platform in ways that the law
allows speech to persist to be able to
be expressed then everybody should be
able to be heard what they do outside
the platform I don't think we want
social media Facebook saying oh this
person did something terrible off the pl
platform now we're going to ban them
otherwise we're going to have big Tech
sensors who sit in Judgment of
everybody's
Behavior the platform right but on this
Alex Jones did use Twitter to amplify
his disgusting lies about Sandy Hook and
he will now be able to monetize all of
his conspiracy theories to his heart's
content on X without having paid a
single dime of the 1.2 billion damages
awarded against him which should be
going to the families of the Sandy Hook
victims that he so cruy defamed that's
my problem with this is he's not just
any old Joe who got deplatformed has got
brought back this is a guy at the center
of the biggest defamation case in recent
times who hasn't paid any of his dues to
these people
but appear if he monetizes his platform
on X that is income that those
plaintiffs will easily be able to get
and if he uses the platform to spread
conspiracy theories or defamation that
falls outside of what fre speech Absolut
L is and I think Twitter would be
justified in Banning him but what do you
do you ban people forever if they say
something defamatory like I said there
are people who have done a lot worse
than Alex Jones who are using Twitter
including bringing about war lying to
deceive the public in elections and I
don't think that we want this standard
that says anything other than as long as
you say things that are within the first
amendment you should be entitled to use
social media once you don't you should
have a just punishment he's been banned
for many years now and I think Elon Musk
is saying okay it's time to bring him
back and see how he uses the platform
but you see my my criteria has always
been that if you were a world leader uh
or an elected official actually of any
kind at any level then I think
everything that you tweet should be left
on the historical record in perpetuity
right we had a big issue here with
ministers losing their WhatsApp messages
The crucial part of the pandemic
shouldn't be allowed it should all be
public property this kind of stuff so
I'd separate elected officials from
ordinary people like Alex Jones but what
Alex Jones what about journalists what
about journalists who who who Li the the
UK and the us into war there are plenty
of those people who still are doing
those things they're still lying people
into war they're still lying about wars
do are you comfortable with
having Jud Glen what about Nazis I mean
you've defended Nazis in the past
because you're a free speech absolu as
as a lawyer so why is that some people
get more power when it comes to free
speech more rights when it comes to free
speech but others don't again this is
not a Level Playing Field act she's
she's complaining because nobody has an
interest she's complaining because
nobody has an interest in watching her
show or listening to her on Twitter
the
AL talking about alms in which people do
not have equal rights so you're using
that's not the case at all that's not at
all assuming that you're assuming that
Alex Jones has the same rights as
everybody else on Twitter and that is
just not true you know what listen it's
a it's a very intering debate I wish I
could talk about it longer we run out of
time but thank you all of you all I
would say is personally there has to be
a line with people like Jones who commit
atrocious defamations are not held
remotely accountable for it and are then
welcomed back like free speech Heroes
they're not free speech Heroes he's a
hate speech monster for me but anyway on
another sensed You can disagree as you
have so good to see
you